l' enquête dont on commence à peine et
la grande question c'est le silence de
l'équipage pendant la chute n'en sera
sans doute plus dans les heures qui
viennent sur ce qui est arrivé aux
pilotes
en attendant voici une reconstitution du
vol de l'airbus décolle donc de
barcelone à 10 heures du matin à
destination de düsseldorf à 10h30 un
contact a lieu entre le pilote et le
contrôle aérien français à 10h31 l'avion
commence à descendre sans autorisation
le pilote ne répond pas au rappel du
contrôleur aérien
10h40 l'avion disparaît des radars
l'équipage n'émet aucun appel de
détresse tout au long de la descente en
8 minutes
l'avion perd 9000 mètres d'altitude
avant de s'écraser en pleine montagne